[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's your first look at scavengers and
I'm now here with Josh homes from
midwinter Josh tell us a bit about your
studio
yeah well so midwinter's a new studio up
in Seattle Washington we're a relatively
small team we're just over 20 people
many of us come from triple-a background
working on titles like Halo and
battlefield and this is our first game
as a new studio
all right so scavengers we got a tease
of sort of the world they're some of the
characters what kind of game is it
so scavengers is a survival shooter
coopertition it's it's a game where
teams need to cooperate to survive but
compete to win so what we're doing is
we're taking all of the aspects of a
survival game is sort of condensing that
into a replayable session-based
multiplayer experience awesome all right
and if people want to learn more saw a
little tag there to sign up right yeah
yeah for us it's it's so important to
have players have a voice in shaping the
game and and so starting in 2019 we're
gonna be having play tests and people
can go right now go to scavengers game
comm sign up and you'll be among the
first to play scavengers in 2019
awesome all right well thank you so much
for putting that together it's an
amazing world premiere first look at
scavengers Josh sign up for that now all
right it's now time to present our next
award and please welcome the frontman
from panic at the disco to do it
Brendon Urie
[Music]
[Applause]